I'm George mount from the UI toolkit
team and I'm here to talk to you about
Android data binding before we started
this I thought some random Android
developer out there for some help in
this talk and I'd like to introduce you
to I'm sorry what was your name no one
two three random want you three why
should come up here I I stole I don't we
don't mind I had some friends in the NSA
I you know looked at your laptop and put
it up here on the screen you guys Shh
don't tell anyone
Michael right so I love Android I love
that little green robot but they do
offer some parts thrill is terrible like
I'm writing so much cold church it's
like why is this like this why all this
like all stupid code here yeah I don't
need that I can remind you body I mean
like this product image set that set
this set is like why did I study
computer science for this I don't think
so yeah
that's what I think we gotta have
something better better than that right
do you have something in the box I do
let's talk about Android databinding
okay
bling did you see it let's look at your
code in a little bit detail I see this
set party why are you using calling from
on create right that's just a pain let's
get rid of it
we don't want that instead let's look at
this on create let's instead just bind
your layout to this binding code and
then set the product on there and let
the binding take care of all the work
hmm sound good
a little better let's see how about that
I'm Scott all right let's look at your
layout wow you have a lot of ellipses in
your layout man what's up with that all
right so to make sure that we understand
that it's a data binding layout first we
add this layout tag to the outside and
then we get this variable the the prod
variable that we set in the in the
oncreate right and then we can use that
part of arable anywhere in our layout so
instead of this ID we can now access
that pod lay a pod variable so for
example in the source it's a it's an
image drawable so we can access it
directly the prod name the product name
it's a string and same with the
description there is a bug door oh there
you go you set a price the crash shoot
all right well our price is well if you
look at the code there it was a it's a
resource right and our resource is
coming as a string and it's doing a
format we should do better in our
expression right I expect I think so all
right so one good thing is that now we
can access our layout our expression
stuff directly in our layout so we can
have this access to this string resource
right there and pass a parameter we're
passing the product price as a parameter
in our resource no layout looks pretty
cool huh
okay so but in my application things are
not always static George I'm cool with
your demo but I have this application
where sometimes I hear a different
layout right like yes there you go
it might be all say like how do I do
this I can need to write more code to do
this well my wine mine mine now you want
everything that you well
we allow you to inside your lay up to
have some little dynamism in there you
can have an expression that says if
you're on sale then show this on sale
sign and if you're on sale you might
also have a different color for your
example it's not very realistic because
my price changes they're a dynamic
website so I do dynamic pricing how you
handle that well you have to at least
tell us when it changes so let's look at
your product your product has you know a
price name and an image you have just
extend the base observable class and
then we mark the things that you can
change that are going to change as
bindable and then you have to tell us
when it changes so we have this notified
property change and the findable part
but like my closest extended base cuz I
can't extend your class that it's not
come on all right all right fine we can
use it an observable interface instead
is that it better maybe this will give
you a little bit of help here well give
you this property change registry so you
can just tell us when that happens okay
so yeah this is a little easier huh it
would be nice if we could just have
properties that are themselves
observable isn't it wouldn't it be yeah
here you can access them as if it was
just the same with the same expression
you know you just say your prod damage
and even though it's not a drawable
itself we pretend that it's a drawable
it's an observable field and it's
observable double double for price
double the price you shouldn't be using
double for your prices all right or if
you have more blobby data like let's
imagine you're coming from JSON and
you're still doing development
everything's up
err you don't know what your what's
gonna be like you can use a map and
that's pretty nice for prototyping seems
interesting abouts multiple layouts
multiple layers well yeah I guess you
have you have two different you have
different variables into empty snow yeah
boy that would be a pain whenever I have
multiple like in one year setting apart
to the other one you're setting apart
list it and it's really a pain you don't
want to have to do if it's on the let on
the landscape do this and if you're in
portrait beside so instead what we do is
we merge all of your variables and we
produce one that has the summation of
all the variables that you need and the
binding will just say oh I only need
these what variables and I'll use those
in my layout the rest of them I'll just
not use it all you just set it and
forget it it's great just like Ronco
right talk about the ball sights oh wait
there's more
you don't need to do any fat more find
view by ID right because now you're all
your expressions are right there in your
layout file yeah well I'd run the
animations and you also put them into
beta whining seems weird yeah well okay
you can still get you still need to find
you already buddy if you have a layout
with a tag of you with the tag and ID in
it then what we do is we automatically
extract that view and stick it as a
public static to put it about final
field in your binding so you can access
it directly from the binding this sounds
good you really don't need five you by D
I don't that's good yeah that stuff is a
pain isn't it also we have these
automatic properties for example here is
this drawer layout right and there's
this really nice setter sets cream color
wouldn't it be nice to be able to just
just tying it so you can just set it
right there in your layout file but
there's no attribute
there's no attribute for that well we
can just kind of sneak in and say Oh set
scrim color that looks a lot like scrim
color right just a set right in front of
it so we just look at it so we're in
color and we just say oh I don't I think
we just say okay if you have this thing
with a data-binding expression in it
then we will look for the set center
with it well that takes them the same
type of parameter so in this case the
color scrim is an inch so we say oh set
scrim color we know exactly what it is
it's just automatic for you
you don't have to create this new
attribute for yourself and everyone's
favorite on-click right pretty awesome
yeah sure but each phase so we have this
as well we can do on-click with
expressions very nice but how this work
we also have well I think we'll talk
about that a little bit we also this uh
if you we have all the other event
handlers too like on long click or on
item select whatever all those things on
text changed on text change is a real
interesting one right because it's a
text watcher and there are three
handlers on there you can just set one
of them two of them three of them
whatever you want
it's pretty nice how much would you pay
how much what's important for most you
would pay for this twenty percent of
course that okay how about nothing
oh no way no no what you like it might
not be nothing depending on how optimal
your code is but it's pretty good it's
pretty good so I want to bring up my
co-conspirator in this let me introduce
you to eat we are
hey every day I meet from the UI toolkit
team on data mining with Church I'm
going to go into some details on how it
actually works
so as you're showed before the layouts
are little different now you have a
layout take in the route this tells us
the set data winding layout and we pass
it into the layout grinder which
processes your layouts and then expose a
new layout that the older Android
versions can understand which doesn't
have the layout take anymore we move the
namespaces to your first child and it
also has some sub products from the
processing it creates a class it creates
all these like public final fields for
your wheels with IDs and it creates the
setters for your variables so you can do
detail this is what actually is
happening we move that namespace to your
first child gets it off the layout tag
and this is done while their application
is compiled by Gradle and then we remove
your expressions add some text there so
we can find those weaves afterwards and
if you had an idea we would keep it
there and also create the wheel as you
can see there directly matching the
Spotify you don't need to cast any more
because we know what type it is at
compile time which so we just create a
variable with that type okay so how do
we do this so one important aspect of
data binding is that almost everything
is done at compile time so when we see
an expression like this we while your
Java code is being compiled we go check
ok this product we know what type it is
because you told us now I say ok product
ID image product is a image field or an
image Gator we will look for these
things fight that and then ok here we
found this there's a drawable returning
get in which method then we check ok I
have a drawable
there's a source attribute can I set
this tro'ble to this source attribute
and we call set sorcerer the cool part
is we don't need any reflection to any
do any of these things because we do it
at compile time so at run time is equal
to the code that you would write
yourself hey wait a second I thought all
data binding frameworks needed
reflection don't think
not the new one not this one these are
nice
so for example but this is not that
trivial right that example was simple so
you could say my variable set it as text
correct us straightforward you said it's
the user that image the source I cross
that source which has said before which
does not exist this is a problem because
the imagery doesn't have a set source
method it has a source attribute but as
a set image draw with method where you
can pass a trouble
how does data whining know about this
it's done by annotations so we have this
binding method annotation which where
you can say okay this a binding
annotation for a type class image view
they tree with the source and the metal
is called set image trouble so that we
know that attribute source Maps Isetta
miserable if the pass parameters match
we can use that method to run the
binding again this is done in the
compile time what we generate is the
same code that you will do it set in
which trouble a whole team at under so
these are little tricky because
unfortunately Java is Java 7 didn't have
any function parameters you can do them
so the way this works is again we know
the there's a binding method that says
on click match is set on click listener
and we'll look at okay what does it say
on click listener expects or expects a
weave that on click listener there's an
interface oh great and an interface has
one per mom method that will look for
that that handler that clicked matches
that one method sugandha in details we
saw this and then we saw this okay nice
that the handler dot click method
receives a view and this matches so we
create the interface for you so the Java
is happy and now we are going to like
tunnel those calls to her hammer so you
can see everything is matching it just
works
oops to steal my Thunder here all right
binding it up let's talk about binding
adapter spiny adapters are probably the
coolest part about data binding
so let's talk about something a little
bit more complicated in a set text right
we accept text was a nice automatic
variable you can just set text it takes
in a string or actually test takes in a
char sequence but it's pretty close
let's talk about something more
interesting we have this a an imageview
but we have a large URL like a large
data large image data coming down and if
we do this what's gonna happen right we
don't want this on the UI thread it's
gonna load everything on the UI thread
but that's pretty lousy I don't like
that why not so instead I'm gonna use a
tool
how about Picasso right or Glide what's
your favorite in this example
whoever was about this expression try to
use Picasso but my goodness
casteau with contest London that's a
heck of an expression and - what do you
know that's that that's that's like
special language right I don't like this
is just - that we don't want to see that
in our expressions anyway so let's do
something a little simpler instead what
we're gonna do is create a binding
adapter and we're gonna use the the
Android source we're gonna override what
the default behavior is with our binding
adapter and instead of doing the normal
stuff we're gonna try to do some special
so what we're going to do is I set this
binding adapter of course this is an
attribute an annotation on our static
method here and it can be any static
method and anywhere and we're just going
to look for that static method but the
the attribute the annotation and here
we're gonna look for something that is
an image view and it takes in a string
as a parameter okay and now what we can
do is do anything we want in that class
so we have this nice Picasso we can use
the context from the view we can load it
load the image in there and it can be
done all off the UI thread and it's all
kind of magic now I can do image source
is equal to some value it's great but
what if you want to do something more
interesting let's imagine you want to do
have a placeholder for your annotation
now you have to do this with Picasso in
the same call right you can't just say
you know in one call it's called the
load and the other one you do so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna merge it
all together into one binding adapter
and this one takes two kind of
attributes and they can work together
and it just you just take the parameters
in the order that you've assigned them
in the annotation and now you can do
whatever you want in the method and this
case we're gonna load the URL off thread
and in the meantime we'll load this
placeholder image now sometimes you want
to have some kind of instance
information in your adapter and before
we were using static methods right but
what happens if you want to use an
instance all right if there's a static
method it's easy we know what to do we
can call it directly just my class dot
static method call very simple to do and
your the generated binding class that we
don't have how do you get the instance
so yeah I mean we strap take out this
direct what happens where does the
instance come from did you some kind of
instance so what we're gonna do is the
binding framework is going to look and
see oh this is an instance binding
adapter we need to generate this method
on this class this data binding
component class and this method is going
to be called get whatever the name of
your your adapter method adapter classes
and now it's your job your job to
implement this method in prevent this
class so you move to this class and then
you call set default component on it now
there's also ones if you want to load a
specific implementation for a specific
binding if you want but most of the time
you probably want just a default
component that you're going to load and
then you can then we know exactly what
instance we're going to load for your
for your binding adapter very nice now
you can also do this with components now
when you're doing with the component if
you have some kind of state you want to
get imagine this is a cache for your
images right so you want to you know
load the image from your cache first and
then possibly load it off thread in this
case you know we need to go and what
that instance is we're gonna pass it as
a static method use a stack method but
we want to have some kind of instance
that we're gonna share around to all the
different binding adapters so in this
case we need to know
what that static that state is so in
this case you implement your data
binding component but you add your own
method to it okay so when you have your
own method to it we don't know anything
about this method this is something that
you know about but we're gonna pass it
to you as the first parameter if you'd
like now you can do whatever you want so
we have our own cash here that we can
load our data from I still have talked a
little about best practices okay yeah
let's go through some existing practice
makes perfect
this is a Gleeson example so why data
winding allows you to write some
expressions in the example that means I
can just and web service call from my
exam a'right why not there's a click
listener there's an API why should not I
do this you should not do this if you do
this like your application will break
this is not this not what data bindings
or data mining is to put data into your
UI from your model so instead of doing
that have a callback like every
presenter whatever whatever model you
prefer and just follow the call to that
so the Java when you do the real thing
don't try to do like business logic
through your example it's not going to
work but another example a good way is
that I want to change this drawable
based on the user's nature one just
reacted in that case is fine like it's
just what do I see is a super simple
expression based okay because he is an
advantage when you put this when I look
at this you guys okay I know that if the
age is this this UI shows this Drobo
otherwise the other one is very clear it
makes my example better my code cleaner
so that's okay so you to decide it for
yourself well if you do something like
this where they just small I do
something otherwise I redacted like I
don't understand what this code is doing
when I look at it when there is a
problem like it doesn't make sense
instead of doing it there's something
more simpler like if the age is this to
display name otherwise late
it and this way name comes from your
model if if your object doesn't drill I
have that field which doesn't in this
case you create a V model that provides
that information or you can make the
variable for your binding layouts I
think he took that from my code I'm
sorry yeah he got they don't groan hey
you can also do like so if your real
model can dispatch you and swim in this
example we make this displayname
bindable where in return data winding is
going to generate this BR clause similar
to the art class but for binding of
things and many users last names said
you can displace that it has change and
data winding will keep the you up to
date this is very like if your so if you
value objects and you're directly
showing them in your UI that's okay to
set them as variables in your layout and
then said to me your generated binding
costs but if there's nothing is if you
need more information consider using a V
model while you put this information
there and you can just use these
observable convenience fields we provide
in your view models you just set them
and data mining makes sure of that they
are visible on the UI by the observables
are not like those convenience also root
causes we provide they're nice if they
are very few if you try to make your
value objects with those things you're
just using out of memory for no reason
don't do that but they're they're nice
if you remodel or you can have them in
your activity if there's something you
have to easily control so there's an
another example where you write a mere
model extending the base observable cost
because you don't want to use those
coming it causes the same example here
when you demand the data changes you
notify and then data writing takes care
of this or you can implement the
observable interface now we provide this
program to change registry class which
allows you to dispatch events all you
have to do is just not by properties
change through that cost and let me and
then remove callbacks to just send those
calls to this class and it'll
care of it the other part is like did
this is a video for example I know many
people is been asking for this font a
trivet in text see that we never did
there's some some reasons for that you
can accelerate and someone Lisa I don't
know she's here she's created this thing
where I could set my fonts Innings ever
I wanna do that is much cleaner and this
became very popular I like this example
because like the good thing about this
example is it makes your example very
clean you look at it you understand ways
trying to the and there is no edit
performance cost in all of these things
so you write a binding adapter that says
I know how to set a font on a text view
it's all well defined and in this code
you get the font we load the top face as
set it on the textview if this was a
real application you would probably cash
it so that you don't keep reloading the
font beautiful okay
good example is the original Apter so
I'm using another image loader here
glides and where I could say this Raptor
knows how to set a photo URL and might
have a default but they are not required
so that if there's only a photo URL set
on that view we will still color adapter
the other value will see a default value
which is if it is an object it will be
now
the integer will be zero and like all
the default values you can imagine this
way I can write just one adapter that
can handle multiple attribute groups and
if design is this method you can just
create a subcomponent button plus the
data binding component and just returns
your image adapter this is very nice for
testing so that while the test is
running you can basically set the
default or do nothing because no one was
to call network during a test unless you
are testing network so I have this mock
version here that I inject during my
test and it just does nothing uses the
default role
and that does nothing so this works all
of it
dependents ejection very well actually
you can just say inject image adapter
create this app component and for
example if you're using beggar - this
will take care of the rest you don't
need to do anything else and this is a
dagger - implementation where we always
say I mean we create the model for the
stuff and we say we implement this and
then there is the rest of the codes
assuming that your providers and thank
you okay we were super fast so we have
time for lots of questions there are two
microphones left all right
please use on test questions
hi so my question is about so when you
use data mining it's not always obvious
what's happening in the UX editor if you
understand what I mean so we would be
nice to have to be able to provide like
a default product or something to mock
so I can see what a UX looks like in in
the editor as well yeah that was one of
the first things that we talked about
when we were talking to the Android
studio team and they were really excited
about data binding but you know they're
working on as you saw in the last talk
they were working on some pretty
exciting things right now and so they're
going to get to it but they're not there
yet
I mean I can tell the cold collation is
coming it's very cost so that's that's
good news for data mining and there's
also things we should
is it possible to inflate view stop
according to that data binding
you said inflate new stuff new stuff new
stuff oh yes
yeah so viewstub there's a special
implementation for you stub because you
stub is a as you saw we have final
classes the final fields so we have a
viewstub proxy final field for that
because view step actually replaces
itself with a view so we can't do a
replacement for a final field right so
we have a few sub proxy and you can get
either the view stub or the or the
replaced view with it depending on its
status okay and it is possible to pass
data model to like underlying clay out
yeah so when you created you use the
same expression as if you are passing an
attribute and if there's a binding for
that cause we know to create the binding
for that class and pass that variable as
the variable changes cool thank you
hello current design tab inside Android
studio sometimes it doesn't render
layout correctly yes sometime there is
just black screen or something like this
I'm going to improve this and will it
work with data bound binding also so we
are we're constantly improving the
Android studio layout editor so that's
gonna get better and better over time
absolutely okay thank you I was
wondering you shot the image loading
examples yes how would you go about
cancelling the loads when your you are
torn down somewhere you you have the
bindings
so you can mullet so for example you
create the binding like how what what
are you trying to Castle is the let's
say you were trying to load user image
URL and then they mature I'll disappear
tour now I mean like in Picasa you can
pass attack and then cancel every loads
on those tags for example when your
fragment goes away or something like
that you could be I mean one option will
be passing that tag as well to the
binding adapter and now you can castle
through Picasa or if there's some
variable in your model that can control
that then again the binding adapter can
handle the castling okay that's no
really a callback for tearing down you
compress a callback variable if you are
for for the wheel steering down no there
is no I mean you know when the view is
going away through the Android view life
cycle and there are callback methods
that you can assign to this binding
class you can even say hey like stop
don't rewind I know they they ban the
data changes the generated binding
Clause calls your Kovach I'm about to
rebuy it and then you can say no don't
stop boundary bind and you say that you
are responsible to tell it to remind
whenever you want which is very useful
for if you are using in this side the
recyclerview it's like who gets really
upset if you update the views themselves
directly so if your I think it's
recycler view adapter you say not bond
change and then transit through the
recycle reviews like item change for
okay I think that answers my question
what's the best way to debug the
expressions that are in the view markup
because it's it's logic effective so if
there's a bug how do you do bug it how
do you step through it
well they well you can step through the
code this code the source code that we
generate is actually visible to you it's
it's generated and you can step through
it if you need to it's a little it's
it's a little bit on the uglier side
because it's generating code but you
can't step through it okay but you
should try to limit like how what your
expressions look like now we have some
things that are make it a lot easier for
you so that you'll have fewer bugs for
example we have an old coalescent
operator which i don't know if you guys
those of you who've used other languages
or know what this is but essentially it
says if the first part is null then do
this use the second part and we also
automatically do null checks eye on your
expressions so if any part of it is null
then the resultant value is the default
value so if you call set text on user
dot name then if user is null then the
whole expression is known so it's not
you will see fewer bugs from that and
you know you should like like in the
best practices you should limit your
expressions so they're not too
complicated yeah hello so what are you
doing they're using data binding with
recycle views actually the documentation
says that we should after getting the
view passing the view to the view holder
and get the binding clause we should use
as the Kunik execute pending bendings i
want to know exactly what is it like
because I try to use on ListView and
didn't it didn't call that matter and
work fine it will work fine but it will
so data mining as the variables change
we don't instantly go and update the
wheels what data mining does is we we
just keep track of them and wait until
the next animation frame happens this
helps us to run less expressions becomes
more efficient plus you can change your
data on any thread you don't need to be
on the main thread while changing your
data and data mining will take care of
moving it to the main thread now the way
this works is you wait until the next
animation frame from a recycler wheels
perspective or for the ListView what it
does is it calls your own mine method
and it expects the wheel to be updated
when that method returns so if there is
any textview that you should have set
the text when that happens
otherwise the we won't be measured
properly the first layout will be wrong
the next animation frame recycle they
we'll update that vo that's going to
cause another layout which will correct
itself so it will look like it worked
fine but he actually did two layers for
no reason
sorry by calling execute planning
bindings you synchronously like sync all
the wheels with your model so that data
mining is not going to look at the
layout and the listing will recycle we
will run the proper layout calculations
so the last one when you're importing
variables such as Android the view class
the base view class you use an
expression at least I want to know if on
the new Android studio we actually have
a error fix because if you try to do
that expression of setting visibility
they actually show you an error even
after compiling so I want to know if
that fix or I understood you said for
compiling I shouldn't show you errors
for sure no there's a very detailed
problem but we while passing your
expressions we use outlet we say like
Grandma parcel is very popular and but
that that model doesn't work on IntelliJ
so IntelliJ suggests using another
parcel called flex J flex so sometimes
these grammars don't match properly so
if you about just report the time we
will try to fix it we are working on
some other solution that wants to use
out there person inside IntelliJ but is
like fundamental different models so
it's not very trivial but we are working
on making it more reliable cool all
right thank you